keeping in mind the the Freddie Wong and
his whole crew and Issa Rae in the storm
with those people in mind what would you
say are the ideal platforms for
distribution for short films well I mean
it's different from there's different
different platform distribution I mean
you look at for instance like those guys
they're on they already made their own
you know essentially we're on YouTube
and your channels really really Boman
you have you know subscribers and a
six-figure range and you know you're
really doing very well that's their
distribution right there or you go to
you know there's other channels that
acquire stuff or acquire the filmmakers
are not quite as fun but pay the
filmmakers to to either choir concert or
make content for them on their channels
referring back to like machinima and the
other companies that's what that would
be for them that's what that goes for
the short films specifically more of
these standard like I guess they use a
more standard but the the shorts that
are made in a more traditional sense you
know for us a big partner in any company
that obviously is out there acquiring
films is shorts HD sources D is acquired
films for years our festival and you
know comparable to some some
distributors out there it's it's a fair
way to pay I mean I know the European
distributors some companies out of that
they pay very very well and then shorts
in Europe is treated differently there's
war films the distribution there on
television they're you know they're
producing content like did I definitely
look at shorts in a different way they
were much more a bigger love I guess or
respect and there's actually more money
involved when it comes to shorts in
Europe but the shorts HD the Quirinal
content the festival and they're
different because they're gonna showcase
stuff on to on TV and and you can't be
online so their deal is is TV only you
can't be on the internet while you're
actually you know on the channel so it's
a two two two two different things right
there I mean if you have something
YouTube that contents not gonna be
acquired by Shore City they can they
can't play your film they want we can
deal with you but if you're in the
traditional sense doing festivals and
you haven't gone online you don't want
to be online you can be on shore
and be on television and on their side
only but not on you know on other sites
and get Gracie over there so that's what
happened but it's a different Avenue
then going to you to rock or you know
that because that's there's just two
different things the way they treat it
and other companies are like that other
distributors that are on television they
don't want their stuff I guess they're
like I only gonna want to loo they don't
want to be on the internet as well as be
on the channel they want any sort of the
time they had an exclusive so this is
some of the ways you know get you should
be sure some of the avenues to go but
they're little different there's the TV
kind of route where it's for the time
being they acquire you film it's
exclusive and you have stuff online when
it's a whole different world and and
they don't really generally merge
because again these these these TVD
sugars don't want it they don't to buy
films that are on TV and that they want
on TV exclusively that was the point of
having the film both you know online and
TV HD doesn't work for them so that's
the some of the ways in distribution
you